no fur for my audience and I've talked
about living a kind of more minimal
lifestyle for a while but you guys kind
of started this entire trend or just in
my eyes you did we are the minimalists
because the domain was available for
seven bucks so so yeah we I wish we
could say that we came up with this idea
but I think you know because we're the
minimalist people think about us when
they think about minimalism yeah but
this ideas been around for so long right
yeah I guess like Zen like masters yeah
go back to the Stoics and yeah yeah it's
it's a it's an answer that's been around
for a long time I think we have a
different problem now and I think but
it's an answer that's been around for a
while so what was the point where you
guys said I'm gonna go buy this domain
like what was the tipping point where
this felt like [ __ ] like I think we need
to change our lives and in some way well
I think it took a while to get there I I
stumbled across minimalism through a few
folks there's a guy named Colin right
I'm not sure if you're familiar with him
but at the time he was like this 25 year
old entrepreneur and everything he owned
fit in his bag and there are a few other
people like Leo pabout Cortney Carver
Joshua Becker and and it was after two
events happen in my life
so back up a little bit you know Ryan
and I both grew up really poor like a
dysfunctional households alcohol drug
abuse no money food stamps government
assistance and of course we thought the
reason for our discontent was the lack
of money that we had so when I turned 18
I went out and I got an entry-level
corporate job and I spent the next
decade sort of just climbing the
corporate ladder and by my late twenties
I'd achieved everything I ever wanted
the the six-figure salary the the luxury
car is the the closets full of expensive
clothes and all the stuff really yeah
all those things that you're supposed to
buy it's almost like this template the
American Dream we've been sold this meme
of the American Dream as a as a template
like follow this this recipe and then of
course you're going to get the the
results of happiness that's the result I
was after but it turns out that like it
wasn't a lack of money that made me
discontent growing up it was like these
repeated bad
decisions and making money throughout my
20s just amplify those bad decisions
because now you have money that you can
enhance those bad habits and and so I
along with all the suppose that
accomplishments I had a lot of debt and
stress and discontent in my life and two
events happen in my life when I was 28
years old my mother died and my marriage
ended
it was both in the same month and and it
was really those two events that forced
me to look around and and sort of
question what had become my life's focus
I realized I was just so focused on all
the wrong stuff and so I started
simplifying I stumbled across thankfully
was minimalism and it wasn't like
Jonestown or some sort of coal train oh
hey you know I'm just looking for
answers and the first thing I saw was
this guy on Twitter who who owned 52
items and and that allowed him to travel
around the world and and that was
interesting to me although I don't not a
big fan of travel so I didn't want to be
like this peripatetic writer but he said
this thing called minimalism allowed him
to pursue what he was passionate about
and that was appealing to me but it also
made me start asking more questions like
yeah who was the person I want to become
what am I actually passionate about why
have I given so much meaning to all
these things why am I so discontented
actually and and and through that
journey of finding these different
people who were living minimalist life
that they were all different people
someone had families like Leo Bo Valdez
six kids Wow and and lives in San
Francisco and and what I realized is I
wanted to simplify my life but my recipe
wasn't gonna look just like anyone
else's and that was both scary because I
wanted I don't want another template
well give me the hundred things I'm
supposed to own and that's what I'll own
right but the truth is like the things
that add value to my life are gonna be
different than what adds value to your
life and so I spent the next eight
months after month my mother passed and
my marriage ended just simplifying like
jettison almost everything and I've got
a rid of rid of about 90% of my
possessions over the course of those
eight months and I started feeling freer
and happier and lighter and then
people work notice something was
different two people work so to come up
to me and saying you seem a whole lot
calmer you seem happier you seem nicer
yeah and then Ryan came to me one day
and he said why the hell are you so
happy and so I told him about about this
thing called minimalism but I never
jumped up and said look at me I'm a
minimalist and everyone else should be a
minimalist too and he's like hey I think
I think I want in on that as well yeah
the biggest difference that I saw in
Josh is he started making rules for our
boss things like hey I'm not gonna
answer my phone after a certain time
it's like office space in a way
basically yeah yeah I am yeah that's so
funny like the hyperbolic version of
yeah what we went through yeah
absolutely and I remember that the other
thing I remember is in Josh's home he
when he moved out with his wife when
they split up he moved into his new
place and he didn't have a lot of stuff
and I don't really think anything of it
the one thing that stood out though was
he didn't have a TV and when we when I
first helped him moved and move into his
new place I came with a wall-mount like
already ready for a TV to be in his home
and for us like that was something that
we always prided ourselves on like do we
have the latest you know greatest
technology yeah how many you know how
clear is that picture oh how many do we
have I get it this is like there's no
you notice there's no TV in my main room
here yeah and the reason for that is we
told our builder because they were
putting the house together that goes
with the TV oh god look so good you can
put a big TV and be like we don't want a
TV like TV is a treat we treat it like a
treat where it's like a dessert sports
game that we want to watch or some
documentary or something that it like
we're into and that's out once a week
twice a week kind of thing it's not a
daily thing so yeah it's it's it's an
interesting approach to this thing that
we're supposed to have you know kind of
on in the background like a fireplace
almost yeah and I was I kept asking Josh
like what kind of TV are you gonna get
what time kind of TV
and then eventually he was just like you
know I don't think I'm gonna get a TV it
was just these little small changes and
that did cause me to go to him and be
like dude what is going on with you man
well yeah you have really a suicide
watch isn't that weird though like we as
soon as we start giving away stuff
that's supposed to be the telltale sign
someone's gonna kill themselves is is
I'm decluttering my life uh-oh what's
wrong right our co-workers called me and
asked that I mean they were kind of
joking around but they absolutely did
are you serious Wow and I if it wasn't
for Josh you know what I have ever have
come across the idea of minimalism I
don't know I like to think I would have
but because Josh and I have had been
best friends since we were fat little
fifth graders I thought maybe this thing
that's working for him maybe it could
work for me mm-hmm and I was like all
right you don't want to try this out I
want to be a minimalist I didn't want to
simplify over a nine month period like
Josh had I wanted faster results so
that's where we came up with this idea
of a packing party where I literally
packed up all of my stuff I pretended
like I was moving and then I unpacked
things as I needed it day by day for
three weeks and over this course of 21
days I was really having and gaining a
different perspective on on my life like
the flake I remember the first thing I
unpacked it was probably like a beer
from the fridge but then it was like all
my pacifiers it was the Internet right
it was the TV it's really started
realizing like what I was you know kind
of doing with my time and then also
realizing how much stuff I had and what
I wasn't using so by the end of those
three weeks I mean I had 80% of my stuff
still packed in boxes and like it's all
sitting in the bigger room but like it's
far square-footage this a little bit the
taller ceilings but just sitting in this
room just boxes stacked on top of boxes
stacked on top of boxes and all these
things that I couldn't even remember you
know what was in
what boxes and just realizing like wow I
have spent the last 10 years of my life
spending tens of thousands of dollars on
this stuff to make me happy and none of
its really doing its job so that's
really where the minimalists calm
started is me kind of going to Josh and
I was like dude this is a this is an
awesome experiment that we should share
with other people because I got a lot
out of it I think other people could get
a lot out of this and Josh had written
some some essays and stuff so yeah we
went we went to GoDaddy and we started
we started searching for domains and I
remember Josh sent me the idea for the
minimalists com
and I was like dude if we call ourselves
the minimalists we are gonna be
pigeonholed into being the minimalist
and who are we to say like we are the
minimalist because certainly there
aren't like monks would put us to shame
right yeah like so so I'm talking to
Josh about this and he's like well dude
do you have a you have a better idea and
I'm like I don't I don't have a better
idea he's like well let's just use this
as a placeholder
it's funny how those stick when you like
eventually get used to it and yeah so
now we own it and you know literally and
figuratively I mean I I'm proud to call
myself as one of the minimalists it is
it's it's an honor to really be to be
looked up as like a role model just for
for people to kind of have just
something that they can recipe that they
can look at and they and they can say
you know what Josh and I are cool guys I
don't want to live my life exactly like
them but there are some ingredients in
their recipe that I can apply to my own
life
you